[Music]
[Music]
come on and for your final question my
friends would describe me as kind I
guess based on your answers
your princess PFF is snow
[Music]
I just put here to see his real video in
Captain America the First Avenger
red skull refers to a drizzle the World
Tree guardian of wisdom and faith are we
to believe sir that you're a descendant
of that tree along okay okay thank you
very much um what does Drex really like
come thank you yeah are you a comfort or
fruit berry is me I'll take this one
he has roots I am vanellope click here
to meet wreck-it Ralph hey give a permit
for that pop-up that's unauthorized
you're coming with us
[Music]
way to go my game is
one
she rushes getting up like
Oh No I'm freaking out are dime not
eraser whatever my best friend all I
gotta do is find the part to fix the
game everything goes back to the way it
was
[Music]
my feet don't wanna get my feet go
everyone we're Tracy housewives wanna
meet you do wanna get rich playing video
games slaughter race he's wicked
dangerous attention to details pretty
impressive
well well well who are you
I think we should get out of here
show time that's right
beloved ears ooh there's so many babies
and cats in the world
I want this to be my life
I don't think I could ever tell her Alf
there's no law saying best friends have
to have the same dreams
[Music]
this is what's called the darknet are
you sure this is safe just whatever you
do do not look at his little brother
little brother what are you giving me
huh hmm
the reason I came to your neck of the
face I mean there's a face in your neck
I mean what's neck of the woods
[Music]
[Music]